Okay, listen.
♪ I want grade A beef
so I can sport it ♪
♪ Don't want no brother
with a shortage ♪
♪ If you're small,
then I'm bitchin' ♪
♪ Tellin' you
you're short a few inches ♪
♪ See, I ain't got no time
for a Tic Tac ♪
♪ See, a girlie like me
needs a Big Mac ♪
♪ You know I got to be good
to my Kit Kat ♪
♪ So, all you small-time
brothers, I ain't with that ♪
♪ Don't bring it to me
if it's little ♪
♪ 'Cause I got to have
something in the middle ♪
♪ Make me squirm, baby,
make me wiggle ♪
♪ I want to scream, boy,
not giggle ♪
♪ I want something I can feel
when it's in me ♪
♪ Don't want no stuff
that's skinny ♪
♪ Make my stomach real full
like a muscle done pulled ♪
♪ Like a bitch been eatin'
at Wendy's ♪
Wouldn't call mine
a "Big Mac,"
but can I interest you in
a "Quarter Pounder with Deez"?
Ha-ha!
That old hoochie
rapping about the D
is Jackie B,
and her dong song
was too popular to ignore.
To be clear, we are only
discussing the penis tonight.
You want taint humor,
you take your business
over to Fallon.
If the penis wasn't
the most valuable body part,
then why did God
give it a helmet?
It's like a trophy that
we carry around at all times.
What did we win?
Uh, the gender lottery.
There's no secret
to the goo gun.
Just rub the magic lamp
until the genie
explodes on your face.
Ladies, what's more important,
length or girth?
You're right.
Money.
Shape's the real issue.
You don't want your birthworm
to look like the lonely gourd
nobody bought at Whole Foods.
Having a wiener is like owning
a temperamental ferret;
you have to keep it warm,
clean, and away from children.
Sure, Jackie B's penile code
is a little strict,
but I respect her
as an artist and as a woman.
That's why I flew her to L.A.,
where everyone's
overcompensating for something,
in this week's Web Remix.
[upbeat hip-hop music]
(man)
♪ Yo ♪
♪ Tosh.Yo ♪
♪ ♪
Straight out of cold verse,
your home boy D.T.
in the place to be.
We up here maxin',
relaxin',
stone-cold kickin' it,
live in full effect,
know what I mean?
Word up now.
Today's guest
ain't easy to please.
Put your hands together
for my homegirl Jackie B.
Yeah, come on!
Do the man-lover dance.
Ugh!
[funky hip-hop music]
♪ ♪
- Jackie B?
- Yeah.
How old are you?
Oh, my God.
I don't want to tell you.
When did you start rapping?
I started rapping...
maybe 20 years ago.
- 20 years ago.
- Here, let me show you.
This is one
of my cassette tapes...
- What is that?
- When it first came out.
How do you listen to this?
- Do you plug it--
- Oh, my God.
How do you make
a living now?
I'd rather not say.
But I'll do this.
Huh.
Well, now I definitely
want to know.
Well, tell me about
that particular video.
Actually I was
at somebody's funeral.
♪ Make me moan and groan
when you swing that bone ♪
♪ Like a car,
have my leg all jacked up ♪
[cheers and laughter]
[bleep]!
Ah, [bleep]!
Here's an appropriate rap
for this day.
Right, I was
so wrong for it.
[both laugh]
Is there a man in your life?
There's a very special guy
that's been on my side
and in my corner for years.
- In your corner?
- Yes.
- In all the corners?
- All of 'em.
- Oh.
- [laughs]
Who's your favorite rapper?
Mystikal.
I love him in every way.
Ooh!
Shake that ass.
Yes, show me what
you're working with.
Oh, that was my favorite.
You know, I actually
got beat up off that song.
- No.
- Yes, I did.
How'd you get beat up?
Because my friend
I was dating at the time
always talked a lot,
and he was like,
"Oh, you're gonna listen to him
and not listen to me?"
And he beat my ass
for it.
I swear to God.
I ain't lying.
Jesus,
that's a great story.
What's that guy
up to right now?
Oh, he's passed away.
- Okay, good.
- Mm-hmm.
Does size matter?
To me, it does.
- Does it?
- It does.
Why?
Because it fills it up more
and there's not a lot of air
going through the parts
that you don't want
the air going through.
Approximately how many schlongs
have you seen?
- How many what?
- Schlongs.
- I don't know what that is.
- Weenies.
Oh, my God, I can't--
Because you talk
about so many--
I can't count.
- Over ten?
- Oh, yeah.
- Over 100?
- Yeah.
You've seen
over 100 weenies?
Yes, I've seen it.
I didn't say I was with it.
Describe to me in detail
your ideal penis.
Not too small.
It ain't got to be extra big,
but enough to where
I can feel it,
you know, in my mouth
or whatever.
What's the smallest
you've ever seen?
Like a person just took off
a baby's Pamper,
but it's a grown man,
but his [bleep] never grew.
- Was it a black person?
- It just never grew.
Yeah, mm-hmm.
Black people
do have small penises?
- Some of them do.
- Oh, thank goodness.
- Absolutely.
- Thank goodness.
That is such a myth.
Yeah, well, you know who's
not stopping that myth?
- Black people.
- Right, I know.
What do you think
I'm packing down there?
Well, when you walk up
dressed like that,
it look like
you packing.
Uh-huh.
But when I see you
on your show,
I be like,
"He ain't packing."
Do you know what
the average size penis is?
- Yeah.
- What's your guess?
- 7.
- Pppt!
- Get out of here.
- Mm-hmm.
How do you feel
about balls?
I love them so much.
- Ugh.
- I like 'em on my chin.
What?
Jackie.
All right, Jackie B,
let's talk about
the female rappers
right now.
There's Nicki Minaj,
Iggy Azalea...
- And that's it.
- Right.
What do they have
in common?
Ass.
Huge asses.
Huge XXXL
turd cutters.
Ass.
What do you think
of Nicki Minaj's ass?
I promise to God
her ass is fake.
- But is that bad?
- I don't know.
I'm not a man.
I could care less.
I'd like to give it
a try.
- [laughs]
- Maybe hit it from the side.
Get up in low.
- Would you shut up?
- ♪ Drop it down so slow ♪
- ♪ Boom, boom, boom ♪
- ♪ Ugh ♪
I'm gonna say,
Jackie B,
you might want
to consider surgery--
Mm-mm!
I just want to be me.
I want your lyrics
to speak for you,
but then I want to see
all that ass.
Mm-mm-mm.
Don't cha-ka-lock not.
- All right, Jackie B.
- All right.
Miggity-mad props.
Can't wait to see what
the future holds for you.
That's all the time we have
on Tosh.0
Comedy Central Raps.
We Audi 5000.
Dre!
[funky hip-hop music]
♪ ♪
(Jackie)
Oh, my God.
[laughs]
♪ ♪
[dramatic hip-hop music]
(man)
♪ Everybody try to ♪
♪ ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ I want grade A beef
so I can sport it ♪
♪ Don't want no brother
with a shortage ♪
♪ If you're small,
then I'm bitchin' ♪
♪ Tellin' you
you're short a few inches ♪
♪ See, I ain't got no time
for a Tic Tac ♪
♪ See, a girlie like me
needs a Big Mac ♪
♪ You know I got to be good
to my Kit Kat ♪
♪ So, all you small-time
brothers, I ain't with that ♪
♪ Deliciously thick
and veiny ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Big man wide
as a soup can ♪
♪ That swollen
cocoa snake ♪
♪ So huge
it frightens kids ♪
♪ Oh, whoa ♪
♪ I want something I can feel
when it's in me ♪
♪ Don't want no stuff
that's skinny ♪
♪ Make my stomach real full
like a muscle done pulled ♪
♪ Like a bitch been eatin'
at Wendy's ♪
♪ Gonna get these
to the top, boy ♪
♪ Let me see if you can hit
that spot, boy ♪
♪ Can you make it go riding
like a top, boy? ♪
♪ So tell me,
are you packing or not, boy? ♪
♪ 'Cause if you ain't,
then see ya ♪
♪ And the next man
wouldn't want to be ya ♪
♪ 'Cause when you hit
this thing ♪
♪ You better calm this chick ♪
♪ Make a bitch say mama mia ♪
♪ Big hunk of dark meat ♪
♪ Got its own heartbeat ♪
♪ We're talking 8,
9 inches soft ♪
♪ Daddy, would you like
some sausages? ♪
♪ Put that fat hog
in your throat ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ I want a roughneck
wicked and rugged ♪
♪ But he's got to be packing
that luggage ♪
♪ No half stepping
on the D side ♪
♪ So if you're packing,
then let me see your beef rise ♪
♪ Is it long?
Is it hard? ♪
♪ Will it make me say,
"Oh, my God"? ♪
♪ Is it thick?
Is it pumped? ♪
♪ Can you pack it up
in my trunk? ♪
♪ Long dong silver ♪
♪ Biggest girth on Earth ♪
♪ Oh, hey ♪
♪ Thirsty for that girthy ♪
♪ ♪
(McKnight)
♪ Thirsty
for that girthy ♪
♪ Got a holy fat wiener ♪
♪ With all ten fingers ♪
♪ All ten fingers, baby ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ That wiener ♪
[applause]
If that beat
sounded familiar to you,
know that we did not
rip off Marvin Gaye.
We ripped off
Alan Thicke's whiny son,
so if you're gonna sue anyone,
sue him again.
And a big thank you
to Brian McKnight
for singing
into my dick microphone
while playing my dick piano.